i only had one audition for it and um i
was on my way to new zealand doing uh an
independent film called the other side
of heaven
and i had 26 hours in los angeles and i
said well hey let's let's do some
auditions while i'm out here you know
why not
and so um i said hey princess and
actually back then it was called the
princess of tribeca
i said can i audition for that while i'm
out here and they said well they're
worried that you're a little old i'm
like please just get me an audition and
i swear i won't let you down
and i got the audition and i got the
call that night saying they want you to
screen test i said
that's fantastic i'm going to new
zealand tomorrow i'm going to be 6000
miles away how do we do this
and so luckily gary uh believed in my
audition enough to give my audition tape
to disney
uh along with the screw the girls who
got the full screen test
and disney liked it and and i got it me
a princess shut
up i was woken up with a call that i got
it
and i was so happy because i really
wanted this role and it's such a
brilliant role and it's working with
such good people
and it was really a dream come true